[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
heute gibt es ein grundrezept ich zeige
euch nämlich wie ihr die perfekten paar
kartoffeln zubereiten können und zwar
können die bratkartoffeln entweder aus
rohen kartoffeln zu bereiten die in
scheiben schneiden und dann schön
anbraten oder aus gekochten kartoffeln
und ich muss euch sagen dass ich die
version aus gekochten kartoffeln viel
einfacher finden zum einen weil es
schneller geht und zum anderen weil es
eben einfacher ist und gerade wenn ihr
schon wisst ob sie am nächsten tag
bratkartoffeln machen wollt dann kocht
die kartoffeln gern schon am tag vorher
ab lass dich schön abkühlen und
verwendete dann oder wenn ihr sagt
schnell wir haben sogar einfach noch
kartoffeln übrig weil wir salzkartoffeln
hatten könnte immer schön brav stoffel
daraus zubereiten
am besten nehmen ihr euch jetzt eine
sorte die schönen festkochend ist eine
leckere sorte vom bauern vor ort am
besten
und wenn es neue kartoffeln sind dann
könnt ihr sogar die schale dran lassen
dann müssen sie nämlich gar nicht
geschält werden und ihr habt echt viel
viel weniger arbeit bei bratkartoffeln
ist es so dass ihr sie am besten in
einer eisen pfanne anbraten und eine
eisenstange sieht normalerweise so aus
wenn sie schon richtig schön benutzt ist
die wird auch von mal zu mal dunkler und
hat irgendwann eine richtig schöne
schwarze schicht die nennt sich patina
weil man diese schicht eben ein brennen
muss da jetzt die kartoffeln schon
vorgekocht sind werde ich jetzt erstmal
den rahm spinat zu bereiten dafür
verwende ich einen esslöffel butter ist
eine zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe 1 esslöffel
mehl eigentlich nur spinat frisch oder
tiefgefroren
jeweils 150 milliliter milch und sahne
muskatnuss salz und pfeffer dann gebt
ihr jetzt zuerst die butter in einen
großen topf und lasst die butter
schmelzen und zwar so weit dass er schon
leicht braun wird also ich brauche ich
eine schöne braune butter so nennt sie
sich dann und so lange kann ich schon
mal die zwiebel und knoblauchzehe
schälen und dann fein würfeln
wenn die mutter dann schön braun ist
habe ich hier sieht man hier auch ganz
gut dann könnt ihr jetzt die zwiebel und
knoblauch mittel dazu geben
[Musik]
das könnte jetzt hier schön 23 minuten
lang anbraten damit die zwiebel und
knoblauch würfel schön glasig gedünstet
werden können ich habe jetzt hier tief
gefordert spinat denn momentan ist keine
spinat saison spieler hat ist nämlich
ein wintergemüse und wächst nur im
winter aber tief gefroren bedeutet auch
dass es praktisch erntefrisch direkt
eingefroren wird und deswegen auch die
ganzen vitamine behält und ich muss
sagen dass ich oft lieber tief gefroren
und spinat nehme als frischen klar der
hat immer viel wasser also das sieht man
hier ganz gut wenn er sich mit ganz viel
wasser eingefroren arbeit ist verkauft
später sowieso ihr könnt aber auch gerne
auftauen lassen und so ein bisschen
ausdrücken da wird halt oft immer
bisserl geschummelt gegen den
supermärkten da schon immer ganz viel
wasser drin schön viel gewicht
dann aufpassen dass die zwiebel nicht
verbrennen die jetzt das mehl dazugeben
es gibt eine schöne mehlschwitze
und das so ein bisschen aufschäumen
lassen bislang mit beraten
und dann gebe ich jetzt gleich den
spinat dazu frischen spinat solltet ihr
vorher blockieren also einfach mit ein
bisschen wasser abkochen und dann
abschrecken aber wie gesagt beim
gefrorenen muss ich das ups
[Musik]
jetzt der spinat da drin und dann kann
ich jetzt mit salz und pfeffer wollte
ich sagen ich bin die zange und milch
aufgießen
[Musik]
da stelle ich jetzt die hitze einfach am
herd runter dann kann das ganze noch so
ein bisschen köcheln aber ihr müsst den
spinat jetzt nicht kaputt kochen also
fünf minuten reichen auf jeden fall mit
salz pfeffer und muskat abschmecken und
dann ist auch fertig da gebe ich den
deckel drauf und kam dann gleich die
bratkartoffeln zu bereiten
[Musik]
ihr könnt den spinat übrigens auch gern
für ihren ich muss aber sagen ich lasse
ihn lieber so da haben wir noch bissl
was zum weißen
das war's dann schon dann packe ich den
zur seite und macht die bratkartoffeln
habe ich hier meine eingebrannte eisen
pfanne und da kommt gute schmalz rein
ihr könnt natürlich auch in öl nehmen
aber butterschmalz hat einfach den
buttergeschmack und hat trotzdem den
vorteil dass man es hoch erhitzen kann
sodass es nicht verbrennt
dann schön hoch erhitzen
und die kartoffeln ihr könnt jetzt
entweder scheiben machen oder auch
kartoffel hälften oder spalten finde ich
echt lecker
dann habe das bislang größere
bratkartoffeln und alles was ihr später
noch dazu geben wollt zum beispiel
zwiebeln oder speck oder was auch immer
ihr möchtet könnt ihr dann ganz zum
schluss dazu geben damit die
bratkartoffeln auch schön knusprig
bleiben und wichtig ist einfach dass
jetzt nicht zu viel auf einmal in die
pfanne kommt sondern eher schön eine
braten seite habt das heißt ich packe
jetzt mit der schnittfläche nach unten
nämlich hier rein und drehe und wende
sie erst wenn es sich unter der kruste
gebildet hat dann klebt auch nicht in
der pfanne fest und dann wird es eine
richtig schöne große kruste und wir
haben später bratkartoffeln die außen
knusprig und irgendwann reich sind
das wollen wir erreichen und gewürzt
wird das am ende
[Musik]
und wenn ihr bratkartoffeln aus rohen
kartoffel macht dann sollte ich sie
recht dünn schneiden denn ansonsten
ganze wirklich sehr lange und dann
kommen sie hier auch in die heiße pfanne
in etwas butter schmalz und dürfen dann
auch erst gewendet werden wenn sich eine
kruste gebildet hat das dauert aber
bisher länger muss ich sagen deswegen
mag ich die version mit den gekochten
kartoffeln und dann kommt immer noch ein
bisschen rosmarin rein salz und pfeffer
und fertig
es ist fertig es gibt bratkartoffeln mit
rahmspinat
richtiges thoma essen
oder aber es macht oder sich gemütlich
ja und lag für uns sowieso weg bei uns
wächst ja rosmarie und
genießen große fische muss man ging so
schnell und es ist günstig bei
kartoffeln kosten ja nicht wieder los ja
das ist jetzt mal gekauft hat sich
erinnern vor zwei wochen muss mal ist
auch rhetorik hat und momentan sind mit
bezug zur realität verloren hast wir
sagen einmal den schuldner gefragt und
danach was gratis spritpreis ist da sagt
keine ahnung ich habe schon immer
getanzt verdient ja und zwar ich kann es
dir ganz genau sagt 169 kartoffel das
kino kommt ich gebe euch jetzt mal
bratkartoffeln und dazu gibt's
rahmspinat spieler
weiß was es gibt kein spieler der saison
sind ja das ist mein gemüse gibt es
nicht es gibt aus der theke 5 gramm
packung 199 das ist ja immer teuer
gewesen 199 mio
ag.com jungs probiert mal ja hier
dankeschön mittagessen
bratkartoffeln ohne fleisch aber was was
auch dazu passende könnte ist sagst dir
gleich die sonne rein fleisch wurst gibt
es übrigens auch ohne schwein und zwar
gleich gänzlich auf wasser schnittfest
weiß ist vielleicht nur der letzte drink
drin ist was ich kann mir das komplette
programm
es in der außen knusprig innen reichen
ja schon mit butterschmalz
wenn man sie doch vegan zubereiten will
weil man keine butter verwenden will
könnt ihr übrigens auch olivenöl
verwenden wenn es nämlich gutes olivenöl
ist ich jetzt keine werbung für unser so
unsolide machen aber wenn es gutes
olivenöl ist kann man es nämlich auch
hoch erhitzen und auch darin frittieren
und karten und gab bratkartoffel
schmecken darin sehr gut ständig kugel
ist ein richtig groß bringen und das
kriegst du wirklich nur in der eisen
verreisen oder bloß weil eine eine
beschichtete pfanne darf man gar nicht
so hoch wachsen
[Musik]
heißt ein bisschen
außen knusprig innen weiß genau wie ich
also ich hoffe euch gefällt dieses
grundrezept sehr gut ich muss dazu sagen
dass es ein sehr einfaches gericht ist
aber ich wurde oft danach gefragt
deswegen habe ich auch zubereitet ganz
einfache gerichte sind hat auch noch die
besten falls ihr noch weitere oma
rezepte kennt oder ganz einfache
gerichte die ich unbedingt mal für euch
nach machen soll dann schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare
und wie gesagt dass das video zu reisen
pfanne zum einbrennen findet ihr auf
meinem technik kanal da könnt ihr gerne
vorbeischauen und da gibt es auch
hinweise zur pflege zur reinigung zur
aufbewahrung und so weiter also macht
gut bis zum nächsten mal guten appetit
gleichzeitig kennen den spruch so ist so
schafft man auch
wir gehen gleich zusammen im garten muss
man
sich gut und reiter macht's gut macht's
besser
beispiel 100 noch drüber und damit
kartoffel zwar sagen
[Musik]